mais au retour des mois chacun fait pas
trop froid je vais monter volontairement
[Musique]
le même monté volontairement sur un
bataclan de briller c'est bien pas ses
visités hier fabien ça c'est bien la fin
de contrat que de les griller oui
effectivement qui est en déplacement et
donc nous allons faire le plein nous
allons chercher des esclaves et donc
nous allons les
nous allons chercher comment tiers de la
main d'oeuvre donc au port comme et
comme on est enfin prévu alors pourquoi
avoir choisi ce thème
ben c'est à dire que ce thème a été
choisi pour de simples raisons c'est
c'est tout simplement on prend avec
humour tout
tout ce qui s'est passé donc à cette
époque là et surtout ne pas oublier la
libération qui a eu lieu il y a
maintenant 150 ans alors locke le
carnaval c'est ça défoule 20 mai le
carnaval c'est aussi passer des messages
aussi portait bien mais s'agissait
surtout sa musique puis de rire de ce
qui s'est passé
en tout cas merci et beaucoup vous
l'avez compris par et je suis monté
volontairement ce coin bâton et oui
messieurs